many adults derive their meaning in life
from having children
having families i don't have children so
it's been very important to find or even
impose
meaning on my life i call mdma the
chemical of connection
this medicine encourages you to reach
out
and figuratively or literally touch
another person
and deepen that connection and that's
been
very meaningful to me
better living through chemistry was the
official slogan of dupont chemicals for
decades
it became the ironic cretacore of
counterculture hippies in the 1960s who
started to experiment with psychedelic
drugs ranging from
lsd to mescaline to magic mushrooms
one of those old hippies is charlie
wininger a 71 year old brooklyn-based
psychotherapist and relationship
specialist who new york newsday
once dubbed the love doctor wininger has
recently come out of what he calls the
chemical closet with his new book
listening to ecstasy the transformative
power of
mdma which is both a how-to guide and
memoir of how this drug
impacted his relationship with his wife
shelly a retired nurse
in 2000 she was out of a bad marriage a
repressive marriage and she wanted to
spread her wings
and fly and she learned that i was
a psychonaut one who does psychedelics
and
this book is largely about our story and
how
mdma can really be used as emotional
super glue for
relationships and added a whole other
layer
of intimacy and closeness for us
whitninger is at the forefront of a
psychedelic renaissance that
consciously builds on the lessons of the
1960s to deliver
not just more effective therapy but what
he calls
serious fun fritz pearls famously said
lose your mind
and come to your senses when i'm high on
mdma
my mind quiets down and i feel
my heart and i feel this central
aliveness this chemical affirmation of
my
spirit and it's like the sun itself
is rising in my heart it's like taking a
chemical helicopter ride above my life
and i can look out at where i've been
where i am in my life and perhaps to the
horizon where i want to go
and then i can come back down and
rededicate myself to
the way i want to be living mdma was
first synthesized by pharmaceutical
giant merck back in 1912 and
rediscovered decades later in the
mid-1960s by maverick chemist alexander
sholgen who liked its ability to
increase emotions and empathy among
users
therapists started using it in
counseling sessions but after it gained
a reputation as a party and rave drug it
was banned by the drug enforcement
administration in 1985.
thanks to the decades-long efforts of
the multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies or maps
mdma-assisted psychotherapy is now at
stage three clinical trials for
fda approval if the experience of
marijuana is
any indication medical use could
eventually lead to the legalization of
mdma for recreational purposes as well
as befits both a tribal elder and a
medical professional
winninger stresses the intentional use
of drugs as a means to an end
in the psychedelic community there's an
emphasis on integrating
psychedelic experiences that is learning
to turn
states into traits learning to turn
the experience of for example a good
mdma
high to translate that into
your life and bring it into your life in
this in a sober way because we spend
most of our time
hopefully sober it's taken a long time
for the culture to largely forget the
polarization and violent polarization
that happened in the 60s
and early 70s and uh
and have that generation gap reduced and
have
traumas like the vietnam war become a
memory
so that psychedelics can now re-emerge
in uh using the medical model as a
healing force uh in the time when
we need healing very much as
psychedelics become more mainstream
and people realize that they can use it
to restore the lost
heart of their relationship or they can
use it to build upon
a good relationship they can use it to
we call it
recreational use i prefer the term
celebrational use
even as weninger says that mdma and
other substances can help shrink the gap
between generations he also underscores
that people's
needs and bodies change with age past
the age of 35 or 40.
the way to keep a happy long-term
relationship
with these wonderful medicines is to not
abuse them which takes some discipline
because
the experience can be so good that you
want to do it again and again
but i limit it to four or five times a
year
that way i can keep it up into my 70s so
we plan these things very carefully
and it gives us so much to look forward
to in life
you